هذا هو ما يسمى بالمرحلة الثانية
من الحرب، الذعر والاختناق
داخل مستشفى الوتز في شمال غزة، الذي
أرعب العائلات والمرضى الذين
ليس لديهم مكان
لتشغيل الغارات الجوية القريبة بعد أن طلب جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي من
الناس هنا الفرار من الجنوب، لدينا
أكثر من 400 مريض داخل المستشفى.
المستشفى العديد منهم في
وحدة العناية المركزة، إجلائهم
يعني قتلهم أمر الإخلاء الذي
وصفته منظمة الصحة العالمية
في الأمم المتحدة بأنه مستحيل، وشددت على
ضرورة حماية المستشفيات والمدنيين
بما في ذلك حوالي 12000
نازح يحتمون داخل مستشفى آل
كوك
بالقرب من الغارات الجوية المستمرة  الآن، تقصف
المنطقة المحاصرة بينما تقوم القوات الإسرائيلية بتوسيع
عملياتها البرية، ويصر جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي على
أنه يقضي على
حماس، ولكن على الأرض في هذه
المنطقة ذات الكثافة السكانية العالية، الدمار المطلق هو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
النتيجة أن هناك مليوني شخص
نصفهم من الأطفال  محاصرون هنا تحت
القصف والحصار، أدى
الألم والرعب داخل غزة إلى
إثارة مظاهرات حاشدة من
مدينة نيويورك إلى لندن إلى روما، وتزايد الدعوات
لوقف إطلاق النار.
صوت أعضاء الأمم المتحدة بأغلبية ساحقة
لصالح هدنة فورية ومستدامة
في الأسبوع الماضي، ولكن حتى مع
دفن العائلات الفلسطينية  أصغرهم، أكثر من
3000 طفل قُتلوا في 3 أسابيع، إنقاذ
الأطفال، حسبما قال نقلاً عن
السلطات الصحية التي تسيطر عليها حماس في غزة، مما أدى إلى تضخيم
الاحتجاج العالمي، رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو يتعهد بأن هذه ليست سوى
البداية، والآن تحذر الأمم المتحدة من أن
النظام المدني ينهار في غزة مع
تفاقم الوضع.
تقول المؤسسة الخيرية البريطانية، إن هناك
انتهاكات جسيمة للنسب الأسطورية
تحدث على الأرض، لكن
إسرائيل لم تردع حتى الآن من الاحتجاج العالمي،
ويقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه يخطط لإرسال
المزيد من القوات إلى
غزة.